We're in Pauli Murray
College and it's sunny,
it's a perfect night.
[choir warming up and
singing chord]
[choir sings "Glimpse Elation"
by Derrick Skye]
(Epongue)
Project 14 is a
collaboration of the Glee Club,
the Yale Symphony Orchestra
and the Yale Bands,
which is multiple
groups in itself.
[singing]
Collaborating together
across ensembles to perform
14 works within the 14
residential colleges, at Yale.
[snapping fingers and singing]
Being back on campus
and performing with
my friends and peers
was incredibly cathartic.
A huge part of playing in
the ensemble is being physically
close and feeling
the energy from the people
who are nearest to you.
[snapping fingers and singing]
[clapping and singing]
To have these performances
in the residential colleges
rather than Woolsey Hall,
I think makes classical music
and new music
much more accessible,
brings exposure to people
who aren't musicians.
[flute plays]
All the composers are of color.
There is a lack of composers
of color, of works of color
in the classical repertoire, or
at least they're not highlighted
as much as they should be.
I am so excited for this project
just to be the beginning of
repertoire by people of color,
by people who are alive.
[instruments being played]
I would hope that someone would
come up to me and say like,
"that was so cool,
I've never heard
anything like that."
That's the kind of music
that I personally
like to perform, things
that push the boundaries
of music and what
is culturally acceptable.
[choir ends song]